[Musique]
donc atteint
soixante ans après les accords d'evian
la france n'est toujours pas en paix
avec la guerre d'algérie il n'ya pas nés
de mémoire officielle ni à plus forte
raison d'histoire officielle de la
guerre d'algérie en france une guerre
douloureuse en france alors que
l'algérie célèbre son indépendance à
l'unanimité depuis 1962 il n'y a pas en
algérie ou quasiment pas de partisans de
la colonisation de gens qui trouvent que
que la présence française était une
bonne chose de gens qui n'ont pas
souffert
de la guerre d'indépendance de vision
différente de l'histoire et plusieurs
points de crispation entre les deux pays
france 24 a interrogé trois historiens
qui ne sont pas forcément d'accord entre
eux
la guerre d'algérie ces cinq minutes
dans un film de plusieurs heures la
conquête a été d'une sauvagerie
absolument inouïe ne s'est documenté par
les militaires qui n'ont fait eux-mêmes
qui raconte sans aucune aucun filtre
dans leur mémoire dans leur courrier le
fait qu'on a sacré compliqué qu'on
violait il ya 50 ans de conquêtes
violente de l'algérie ya la guerre
proprement dit de conquête avec la
reddition d'abdelkader ensuite il ya la
soumission de la kabylie et puis la
quantité d'insurrection et en fait au
fur et à mesure que l'armée française
progresse et avance par la violence sur
le territoire algérien il y à des
oppositions et des grande insurrection
après la conquête des que nous européens
s'installe en algérie les algériens
deviennent des indigènes citoyens de
seconde zone la colonisation c'est une
entreprise de dépossession de la terre
au sens symbolique notre terre et c'est
une entreprise de dépossession de la
terre concrètes parce que les colons
s'approprient les meilleures terres et
il ya des
millions d'hectares qui sont spoliés et
donc c'est république française qui sur
son territoire
pratique et l'égalité des droits en même
temps dans ces territoires coloniaux et
en particulier en algérie qui était
quand même une partie d'une pratique est
ce qu'on appelle on doit appeler un
racisme d'état la loi n'était pas la
même pour les indigènes algériens les
européens vivent en algérie la version
laudatrice de la colonisation
a été de plus en plus contesté pendant
la guerre elle-même il y avait
clairement ont pâti dans les milieux
intellectuels
une contestation de plus en plus vive de
cette vision pro coloniale et plus on
approchait de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie plus l'opinion publique
française avait tendance à identifier
les partisans de la colonisation
à des ad fasciste la d homme d'extrême
droite
enlèvements exécutions sommaires le
conflit a fait de nombreux disparus
aujourd'hui encore des familles
cherchent leurs traces les disparus
algérien sur lesquels je travaille ils
ont disparu du fait d'un système
institué par la république française qui
a laissé son arme est enlevée par
milliers et les gens chez eux la nuit
sans dire pourquoi s'en dire on les
emmenait et on n'avait plus de ne jamais
de nouvelles et certains ne
réapparaissait de plus jamais on
considère qu il y a eu aujourd'hui plus
de 3000
européens d'algérie
enlevé après le 19 mars 1962 et parmi
ses plus de 3000 personnes enlevées il y
a eu près de 1600 qui n'ont pas été
retrouvés vivants c'est vrai que sur le
plan humain la souffrance de la
disparition est absolument la même
que l'on appartienne à un groupe qui est
subi massivement des disparus ou pas
néanmoins au plan historique
on a affaire à des phénomènes qui n'ont
absolument pas la même ampleur les
disparus algérien son la masse
conséquente des disparus de la guerre
d'ailleurs ils sont tellement nombreux
compte pas les compter
outre tensions entre les deux pays les
archives coloniales ramener en france en
1962 l'algérie considère que les
archives du gouvernement général est de
départements algériens sont des archives
algériennes et donc appartiennent de
plein droit à l'algérie et doit donc
être restitué à l'algérie or cette
attitude me paraît incohérente par
rapport au fait que le fln s'est dressé
contre la france et donc contre
l'administration française d'algérie
parce qu'il ne considérait que la
version de l'algérie à la france était
illégal et illégitime
en fait sur les archi faux vraiment une
fois encore se débarrasser du discours d
état non toutes les archives algériennes
n'ont pas été ramenés en france mais non
non plus les la france n'est absolument
pas légitime a amené d'algérie en 62
quantité d'archivés ce qu'il faut dire
aussi c'est que côté algérien les
archives ne sont pas ouvertes et que les
algériens l'état algérien dispose
également des archives de certainement
très intéressante mais qui sont
extrêmement difficiles d'accès
depuis plusieurs décennies la france
dont une réconciliation avec l'algérie
restées sans succès à propos de cette
façon qu'a le gouvernement français de
sommets en quelque sorte l'algérie de se
réconcilier avec elle c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez étonnant pour se
réconcilier il faut avoir été amis
auparavant
amis ennemis entre les descendants des
rapatriés des harkis et des immigrés
algériens presque 40% de français ont un
lien avec l'algérie
[Musique]